[Applaus]
hier ist eine ikone der formel 1
michael schumacher wurde in den 90er
jahren zur berühmtesten figur des
motorsports von 2000 bis 2004 legte er
eine bis heute nie dagewesene sieges
serie hin
[Applaus]
schumacher hat eine ganze generation ins
gericht
er war süchtig nach erfolg und widmete
sein leben dem sport
das konnte ja vielleicht noch besser als
haben wir ein top team aufbauen
wir waren drei jahre teamkollegen bei
mercedes unglaublich wie er an die sache
rangehen
bestimmt hat mir das geholfen später
auch weltmeister zu werden spielte immer
eine wichtige rolle in seinem leben bei
erfolgen kontroversen und tragödien
[Applaus]